lebanon's emergency force is busy
fighting fires there's an increased risk
due to a significant rise in
temperatures
already there have been 3 000 fires in a
relatively small sized country
[Music]
the Wildfire season has begun earlier
than usual this year
and it's blamed on global warming
lebanon's nearly bankrupt State makes
the situation worse
the latest vehicle that we have received
was was in 2000 year 2000 so all our
vehicles and tools are old more than 20
years of age
limited resources make it hard to cover
huge areas
in the north a group of volunteers are
relying on donations to protect 180
square kilometers of forests
Lebanon loses up to 2 000 hectares of
forest a year to wildfires and
deforestation
we had to drive an hour on narrow
winding roads to reach this fire the
terrain is steep and rugged in this
region
and these men work under difficult
conditions
their equipment is basic
they only have two vehicles
to cover vast territory
and they have to rely on the help of
locals
we also have a problem of ensuring a
water supply line due to long distances
municipalities like most State
institutions also lack funding and
resources the United Nations is offering
support
what we have seen in the fires that have
risen four times from last year is
they're mostly in grasslands
and that is because these lands have not
been able to be cleaned and we have been
also working through our work at the
municipal level in cleaning forests and
in cleaning grasslands so if there are
fires that they don't spread so fast
Lebanon has already lost 26 of its
forested areas in the past two decades
and that's before the impact of climate
change
a car Northern Lebanon